ちょこっと現代人の不満
納得した生き方ができると思うなと
これ現代人言うんです
納得した生き方ができると思うならできません
だからね 不満が人生です
不満に対して勝てそうもない戦いが人生です
若者に不安が不満があるならば
元気で活発で いろんなものに挑戦してみることですよ
別に どうせ勝てそうもないんだけど
みんな同じだからね 失敗するのは怖い
不満だと言っても無意味ですよ
どうせ生きなくちゃいかんだからね
だから成功しても不満でしょうしね
だからなんで失敗するのは怖い
不満だというんで 成功したにも同じですからね
親も社会も会社も作ってくれるのは不安です
不満です とことん不満を入れるんですよ
注入するんです だからとことん生きてみればいいんです
別に失敗したっても成功したってもね
どっちでも同じだからね
どうったことはないんです
親ぐらい子を安心させると思ったら
それは勘違いです 親も子に徹底的に不安を与え
不満を与えるんです ん？社会です
社会でしょうね 社会も友人も教育も知識も不安
不満 不安です 不満です
不満しか与えません 勉強すればするほど不満になるでしょうに
親が子供にあんた大きくなってもいい大学に入ってください
えらっ不安になるでしょうに
あんた宿題やったの？と言った時
言われた瞬間にどうですかね
気持ちは 不安 不満があるから生きることに挑戦しているんですよ
だから親があんた宿題どうしたのかというと
もう不満で不安で もう嫌で
だから宿題するでしょうに
結局は 皆 生きることを賛嘆しているでしょう
世の中は ということは
不満を賛嘆していることです
苦しみを賛嘆していることです
勝てることに挑戦する
大胆な ですから どうったことないですよ
失敗しても成功しても価値同じだったら
なんで失敗選ぶんですか？例えば
あなたは一日断食したら 1万円あげると約束する
もう一人にあなたは一日ごちそうを食べるならば
1万円をあげると どちらを選ぶ？ごちそうもあげますからね
そこで私はある人にごちそうを用意しておいて
あんた一日断食したら 1万円あげる
これは食べて楽しくいれば 1万円あげる
どちらを選ぶんですかね
普通だったらごちそうも食べて 1万円も選ぶ道を選ぶ
どう見たって 1万円もらいますからね
1万円は だからもう失敗しても成功でもどうでもいいんですよ
もう勝てる道じゃないんだけど
不満っていうのは ですから
まあそれなりに挑戦して生きるんですよ
そのためには大胆な夢は
なら 絶望に陥れるんですね
人の言葉に無批判的に乗ってはならない
親の話にも乗っちゃうとどうなるかわからないんだから
あんまり無批判的 無批判的に乗ってはならないんです
自分に成功できる 達することができることに挑戦してゆく
大きな夢でも小さなコマに切って
一個一個に挑戦してゆく
一個一個に小さなコマに切っちゃえば
一個なら成功できるでしょ
大胆な夢は置いといて
切る 小さなコマに切って
一個一個に挑戦する 欲見
自我などの感情を抑えて
理性に人生を任すんです
感情に任せているんじゃなくて
理性に任せるんです 感情が何言っても聞いてあげない
理性が言うことは聞く
例えば怒ったら殴れと感情が言うでしょ
理性はやべえと言ってるでしょ
それを聞くんです そうだ
相手お前腰抜けでしょう
怖いでしょうと言っていると
また感情でしょ でも理性はやっぱり逃げた方がいいと言うんだからね
理性に身を任せるんです
成功しても過去を置いておく
成功したっても そこはもう無常だからね
次のことに挑戦する 成功を喜ぶ
お祝い暇がない お祝いする暇がないんです
人と忙しいんです ですから
成功しても そんなのは置いておいて
お祝いを置いておいて
次のことに挑戦すればいいんです
過去の失敗も成功も忘れちゃう
それは忙しいんです 今挑戦することに集中する
しかし 必死で生きてみても
何の意味もないことも理解しておくんです
これっていうのはすごい元気で生きる秘訣なんです
成功には一時的な幸福ぐらいはあるから
生きることに挑戦しない道をやめる
だから落ち込んだり怠けたりすることをやめるんですよ
意味がないんだけど ちょこちょこと成功すると楽しいんですよ
別にどうったことないんだけど
それでもこのちょっとちょっと成功することを選ぶんですよ
やっぱり失敗するのは怖いんだから
私はやめたというのはもう話にならないんですよ
人生は何の意味もないでしょうとかね
だからバカみたいに座り込んでいるんですかね
何の意味もないんでしょうね
結局はなくてもちょこちょこと成功すると楽しいんですよ
学校の勉強に何の意味もないかもしれませんだけど
でもあんた満点でしょう
今度今度はと言ったら楽しいでしょ
ああいうつまらない楽しみに挑戦するんです